-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
I'm so happy to have you here.
And, by the way, it's lovely
to have you in another show
that takes place
in New York City.
Excellent accent work there.
-[ New York accent] Thanks.
-Yeah, it was great.
But you actually
got to be in Scotland.
You were there this morning?
Did you wake up in Scotland?
-Yesterday morning,
I woke up in Scotland.
I was there, 'cause
it was Mother's Day in Sc--
'Cause we have Mother's Day
on a different day from you.
-Really?
-You're panicking
that you missed it.
-Yeah, I would've.
I definitely would've.
-Yeah, we have Mother's Day
on Sundays.
I saw my mom, and I was at
a wedding, a lovely wedding.
And my friends got married
at St Andrews on Saturday.
And before that,
I was filming a bit,
and it was also my mum's
80th birthday last month.
-Oh, fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Was she -- She must have just
been delighted, I'm assuming,
to have you home
for her birthday.
-Yeah. It was good.
And actually all of my family
who are alive were there.
-I do want you to know
that we wouldn't have
thought otherwise.
I wouldn't have
followed up with,
"Even the dead ones, Alan?"
-Even the dead ones.
We have old Scottish traditions,
but that's not one of them.
-So, you get to play
a retired CIA operative.
-Yes.
-...who gets recruited
by the NYPD...
-Yes.
-...because a serial killer
is using your book.
-My book which
I've written, uh-huh.
And I'm also sort of a
fuddy-duddy professor
at Penn State.
-Okay.
-There's a lot going on.
-And also I'm a homosexual.
-Yeah, which is very exciting.
I don't want to
just roll by that.
Because it's not the most --
It's not what your
character's about.
-No. See, that's what I think
is great about it, Seth,
is that it's like --
The fourth or fifth thing
of the characteristics
of this person
is that he's gay and married
in a happy, you know,
solid marriage.
And actually what I think
is really amazing
is that most of the times,
especially on network TV,
when someone is gay,
when there's a gay character,
it's like they're gay, gay, gay!
And it's all about
their sexuality,
and usually in a negative way.
So the fact that
this has a character
whose gayness is way down
the list of things
that are most important
about him is a positive thing.
And also the fact that
when you do see
sort of his same-sex life,
it's in a really positive way.
And that's two things
I don't think
are represented enough
in this country.
-Well, it's fantastic.
And I didn't realize --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The first --
It's the first time.
-It's the first time on a
network drama that a gay --
there's been a TV drama
with a gay character
in the leading role.
-That's amazing.
-It's shocking.
-Perfect.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You -- Obviously, this is
a show about the police.
You're a CIA operative.
So you have a gun.
-I do have a gun, yes,
which has been --
It's sort of, uh --
Well, I mean --
I have mixed feelings about that
because I'm very --
I play sort of a cop person
and a CIA person.
So obviously he has a gun.
It's part of the story.
But obviously -- And especially
in the current atmosphere,
I have -- it's difficult for me
to kind of marry that.
But, you know,
I think it's really hard
for people in this country
who are so used to gun violence
just being
an everyday occurrence
and sort of almost an
unacceptable part
of your culture.
From where I'm from,
there was never any idea
of people owning guns.
So it's been difficult for me,
but I have it.
But, you know, I'm quite --
I don't really
ever shoot anyone,
but the only thing I've ever --
[ Laughter ]
In the show, I mean.
The only time -- [ Laughs ]
The only time
I've ever shot anything
is I shot a glass
of poisoned iced tea
out of Whoopi Goldberg's hand.
-Oh, wow.
-Thereby saving her life.
And, also, I'm really bad
'cause there's always those
lovely cop adviser guys
and gun adviser people
who show you how to grip it
and everything.
And I -- I'm, like,
the lead in the show,
so I guess they don't
really say to me,
"Uh, that was rubbish."
But I realized after
the first couple of times
that my co-star Bojana,
she's quite small.
And the first time we come in
and go, "Police," or whatever,
I realized that
she was taller than me,
and it's because my stance for
doing the gun, I go like this.
Like sort of --
Like Broadway, Bob Fosse
kind of thing.
She's so much taller than me
'cause my legs
are so wide apart.
And someone said,
"Why do you do that?"
I go, "I don't know. I didn't
realize I was doing it."
Maybe just to be balanced,
you know?
But that's --
So I'm kind of a --
I've got a sort of slight
Broadway flair to my...
[ Laughs ] As you should.
-Yeah.